[Music]
Cheesecake Totto Buna Yana
Part 1 Iza Paposweep Taylor Great Attack Day
Deese Audi Fuel Cap a bridge Pear
re adwords this feature Preferred Yarn d
1 person Ukecchi News and Poster fun to fold a n
Pop 4  tamu the back af 4 c
1 Cut came to Japan for the first time in 1973. It's a
very popular chocolate and it's
actually a market share. It's the number one product in Japanese chocolate.
Noreve to do
Magical patio pou  dou dou I
don't know about wafers, I go to Kyushu once a week, ng news par nu do car
My name is Yasumasa Takagi
My profession is Atisie  It's not the case since I started to touch the pazu
. At first, I have fashion.
I've done more than 50 kinds of passionate pash, and
I made it by hand. I have more of them.  There is
a product called yeah yeah yeah, and then there is a product called
hmm. At the
very beginning, I make a prototype in the kitchen of my shop and make it like this.
Well, first of all, there is chocolate and
I like wafers.  Prepare it
, add it to the mold with chocolate, and put the wafer that was surely there. It's
still the specialty chocolate.
[Music]
I'm waiting for a new flavor all the time.
There are many consumers
. It's often good to buy it right
away.
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  FEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFER
FEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFEFE.
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Efefefefefefefefefefefefefefeday  Even though
it was January of the main word, the pronunciation came out immediately and it started with the idea of cheering at one place at a 9 o'clock of the examination Aichi
It spreads steadily [Musi
] here
ill dawn It must
e a KitKat principle  I don't want people with a wide range of mysteries to
be pleased.
Car
adem ebner Home trender Mall Spiser Recha Ah
Parker s Par 5
web Gay Bar Parker s down re
big story